Throughout the next few lessons, we'll be talking about factors and terms. We
want to make sure we know the meaning of each word, so let's start by focusing
on the differences between their meanings. Terms are separated by addition or
subtraction in an expression. So this expression has three terms, 3 xy, 4x and
5. Within each term there are factors. So, the factors of 3xy are 3, x, and y.
These are the things we multiply together to give us our term. The factors of 4x
are 4 and x and the factors of 5 are 5 and 1. We could also write 4 time x as 2
times 2 times x. This would be the prime factors of this term. Prime numbers
have only 2 distinct factors. Here's another case where we have 2 factors, 2x
plus 5 is 1 factor and 7 is another. Within this 2x plus 5 factor, we have 2
terms. Positive 2x and positive 5.